[Music]
in take a chill pill news I like pills
pick a champion yes
submitted by the ancient one oh this is
what you should do when you are angry
this I need to learn this tell people
now what do you think you should do
punch be cream into a pillow breathe
I've been learning something sure
sometimes I get angry and now I know
that I'm getting angry before like it's
too late after I get any oh I got angry
what happened right but then now I can
feel my heart and chest like firing up
and the stove is cooking and I go you
should start shaking when you're angry
because that's what happened to mine no
sometimes I'm already calling people
punk ass [ __ ] that Asian rage
did yeah yeah that's a scary thing like
whenever I get angry like for instance I
can really when I was first when I found
out one of my boyfriend I mean my
business starts shaking really bad you
found that out yeah I like hearing
stories uh what happened so I was dating
this guy for about two years and my
friend from middle school I haven't seen
in like [ __ ] ten years called me up
like hey are you dating this person
because my cousin is dating him oh no
and I was like excuse me and then so and
the cousin didn't know about me so long
story short I called her three wait
called him he didn't know she was on the
line he denied everything is she called
him out her bitching him out oh no
yeah and then it turns out that in our
two years together he started cheating
on me multiple times within like the
first six months already oh wow and then
that's when I was like 19 so had no
control over my anger so I drove down to
this place and I smashed his mirror and
holes in the wall oh you're such a agent
you sure it's a big but I was like a
smart angry because what I could have
done is he edits wedding videos I could
have thrown all his [ __ ] into his fish
tank and [ __ ] his [ __ ] up but I don't
want to go to jail that's even what his
gear yeah I don't want to go to jail you
know like I want to [ __ ] be sued and
[ __ ] like that so I just put a few holes
in that girl
yeah damn that's pretty crazy I don't do
that anymore but that's an example of
how not to be angry right so people are
kind of worked on that I'm just too lazy
so that was the first time I caught him
and that's leaked before she gets mad
the second time I thought I was like you
know what man I'm done with you like
you're you're a piece of [ __ ] I'm out
nothing have you ever got so angry you
go to sleep angry you get angry you're
just [ __ ] in the middle of a yell
fest and you get so tired cuz you've
been yelling all day that you just need
a spot and go to sleep and wake up so
you can yell again I have to break
something
like if it's that type of anger I've had
that too you break it you break and
shoot yeah well this is like my sixth
iPhone you've proven you're wrong last
time I brought this I snapped it in half
the one before I actually crushed it
with my hand like this get the [ __ ] have
you taken that and just went boom and
just slammed yeah but usually I have to
be it has to be like very fist I have to
[ __ ] crush something like a The
Incredible Hulk or all the ways you've
broken your phone out of anger I've
thrown it usually it's I have to snap it
I feel like crumbling so you had like
snappish cuz I don't hit somebody else
so I'd rather just break something
instead but but you've never punched
through the opposite wall I mean this
this has completely just how you deal
with your anger
push-ups or I just all I skateboard too
so that helps if you just skate around
can you clear your mind a bit or I just
uh you know I play video games so I'll
play deaths and ears
so pleasant very positive I don't know
it's kind of a weird thing I don't know
if I should bring this up but sometimes
I'm so angry or a masturbation helps I
tried you know that's what once you kid
you could actually just zoning in on
something else and just beat off it's
like [ __ ] then yeah yeah but it's like
hate jacking yeah with your pocket [ __ ]
and just [ __ ] your pockets a dope-ass
fifi but we were doing at the live show
the cats out the bag that's right well I
have a splash lights
I had several - I had one you had one
I wasn't that fond of it no you don't
like it I mean I tried the whole like
like the recommended leave it in a warm
thing of water so it comes out warm and
all that I use a heater yeah you can put
a hit back yeah I tried it I even wedged
it in between the couch so there's
something there and I could just freely
like I did a lot of different techniques
but just nothing beat the real thing I
know but if you don't have like all the
lonely guys out there I I feel for you
if you don't have the real thing that's
why I spotted your Vaseline look at this
max you got a bunch of cool [ __ ]
boy those crackers all kinds of stuff
but I said can I use your vessel I'll
let you know that's the secret
ingredient baffling
that's what I probably didn't do that
just masturbation as a whole that's the
secret
that's the city like real loo that's too
like sex move no hmm
Vaseline is the way to go because not
only does it lubricate your penis you
can put it on your scrotum its if it's
dry down there your balls out you're
like a smoothie you know what we could
we should edit this part more my
girlfriend might watch this oil no
wrinkles or it's like a [ __ ] uh what
is it a pool ball that's it like a fool
no I Real Talk real they used to be
pretty dry dirt dry so get angry or she
find out no cuz it dude
Mike smooth now you're right mine's just
as I moisturize and everything this is
your past life this is pat in the poor
when you did I wanna oh that's pretty
yeah really she's Hawaiian Filipino
[Music]
anyways yes that we're totally off topic
on that once yes have you guys heard of
the Greek falafel Lassa Lassa I know I'm
Moe said falafel philosopher uh
Coulthard no he's one of the not known
ones yes [ __ ] scrote ''tis or
something Oh daddy's so I mean some of
his work he suggests this helpful
suggestion for when you get angry he
says quotes the best course therefore is
for us to compose ourselves or else to
run away and conceal ourselves and
anchor ourselves in a calm harbor and
though we perceived a fit of epilepsy
coming on so that we may not fall or
rather may not fall upon others and we
are especially likely to fall most upon
most often upon our friends say that in
English take out your anger on people
around you so the best one
don't get that like why don't you stay
here and talk to me like [ __ ] I need to
chill I'm like that yeah yes I'm
throwing this back in your face the next
time you do that sir I'm back in my own
yeah I know that I'm like that because
we talk about all the time cuz David
you're you're the one I like to fix
things right I like to fix things in in
there but I still give time it's like
you you'll get I'll give like a 20
minute grace period you know it's like
20 minutes you go by yourself let me go
by myself too and then we'll figure it
out walk around come back but it can't
go on for a night I cannot sleep so what
used to happen doesn't happen anymore
but before back in the day if I give him
his space it'll be like a whole week of
us not even talking you guys have been
through that yeah you don't talk for a
week yeah really I can get pretty
hardcore with hold the grudge he can oh
yeah
and then when he's doing the silent
treatment thing how does that make you
feel angry I would get very angry
therapist do you think you should do
about that talk to me forever away and
that starts another argument because I'm
already angry that whole weekend have
been like boiling my anger up cuz you
don't feel settled cuz for me so he does
a break yeah cuz I use dspace just to
like chill out so I don't curse at you
like you're a male mm-hmm yeah I mean so
when I'm angry oh I curse oh I won't
curse as much but I Durst has been a
couple times where I have and his cuz
she has pushed my punch to the point
like a guy will push my buttons and I'm
like hey if you do that this is gonna be
the reaction but they keep pushing
pushing pushing you you give them that I
give them a warning it's like hey stop
stop stop stop and it's like I don't
give a [ __ ] it's like you'll give a [ __ ]
like that
I felt that you know so it's like one of
those things it's like hey if you want
to treat me like that I could do it back
to you I would never ever place my hands
on you but I will verbally beat the
arrow so you've gotten that close to
someone's face yeah so one time but this
one I was wrong she pissed me off so
much and I was asking her to give me
space and I literally told her like if
you keep doing this like I'm gonna blow
up so just stop as you know no literally
screaming in my face so I turned around
I was like [ __ ] like that and that she
was like why are you one of those things
and I we had a conversation after I was
like hey I don't ever want to yell at
somebody like that ever again so if you
make me into this person I'm gonna have
to leave you because that's not normally
quiet yeah it's like one of those - you
know hearing all the stuff makes me
think of like Asians cuz that we're
known to have that temper yeah I don't
know what that stems from your women are
[ __ ] insane what your women are
[ __ ] insane or what they just that's
it there's not something you're not
raising yeah I know you guys have a que
rape soon yeah and then like it's like
becoming like kind of problematic in my
relationship because like I haven't done
anything to her but she feels it when it
like boils up yeah you know I'm I'm
looking into like maybe seeing a
therapist like your manager manager you
know yeah dude like you know what helps
him a lot so we had a lot of issues with
his anger yeah I got to get way too
crazy and then you like hyperventilate
yeah yeah
I ended up going would you do
mindfulness it's like a form of
meditation but basic you listen to your
breath basically like yeah you find an
anchor point of breathing or whatever
and then you doesn't really work it is
beautiful really I get it made it work
Mary works there work so I know for me
if once I get to a certain like the rest
done dude i black out so boy yeah yeah
there's like a there's like what am I
like a window where I could you know mmm
not go there but once it crosses it's
like like Incredible Hulk like Bruce
Banner - Incredible Hulk and there's no
way to do we call carriage it is because
instead of like anchoring a peaceful
place I want to anchor my foot in their
face it's a different situation and the
weird thing is it happens to all ages
yeah what is that it you could be you
know Filipinos are like the big party
happy animal guys but they're still they
still got the rage like and in the
Cambodians and everyone from the
Japanese the Korean it's like they all
got it Chinese to repress like when
you're a kid you get used to get the
[ __ ] beaten out of you and you can't say
[ __ ] about it and then you know like you
can't fight back and just add just like
rolls over throughout the generation
yeah cuz I used to be like whenever I
got angry I would lash out and I would
try to I would try to find the worst
things that you're insecure about like
even like and I will and I will just say
the worst things possible because I lash
out bad like I'll put your manhood out
there you know and it's just like and
that you've done that oh yeah and I
needed to calm that down but I was young
I was young like I like two years ago I
still do that [ __ ] I don't know I'm
trying to breathe this [ __ ] my breathing
just turns into [ __ ] rage air
growling and I'm like breathing harder
and harder and it's just flames coming
into my lungs and [ __ ] and I'm like
I need some drugs or something what's up
you sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] links in
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]